among the many troubling consequences of
the pandemic is that
millions more children are going hungry
a study by the british medical journal
now the lancet estimating that by the
end of the year an extra 6.7 million
children
under the age of 5 risk malnourishment
thousands are predicted to die from
hunger
the u n then flagging up an urgent call
right now for action
more children are becoming malnourished
due to the socio-economic shocks created
by the pandemic in low-income
and middle-income countries as leaders
of four u.n agencies
we are issuing a call for action to
protect
children's right to nutrition
the report also highlights a vicious
circle that the malnutrition
puts families and their children at
greater risk of contracting and dying
from covid
help struggling to get through too
lockdowns have seriously hampered
humanitarian organizations and
food supply chains and getting to those
critical places
and the worst affected regions are
children living in
sub-saharan africa and latin america may
be no big surprise there but
the numbers reveal a really bleak
picture well you can see for yourself
the covid global slowdown is likely to
see child deaths from malnutrition rise
by an extra 10 000 per month and more
than half a million children again
per month will be struck by the
life-threatening condition called
wasting where dire hunger weakens their
bodies to sometimes
lethal levels tackling the problem won't
come cheap the un
says 2.4 billion dollars is needed right
now to deal with it
well let's talk director sasuke depe
who's the senior
technical advisor for nutrition at the
united nations world food
program hey there thanks for making the
time to be with us much appreciated
uh take us and tell us a bit more detail
about about this report and
and how important it is thank you very
much and good morning
and yeah the report shows that the
consequences
of the covet pandemic all child
nutrition can
be it's from what we know now
as the landsat report says the child
wasting
can increase by some 14 um
leading to an extra 6.3 million children
waste
and that is really just the top of the
iceberg
it's shocking isn't it i mean five
urgent actions are listed to protect
children's
rights to nutrition and of course the
pandemics really brought that home isn't
it um
are these five things going to be
sorted out anytime soon
yeah those priorities really help us
identify
uh how best to protect uh children's
nutrition and families nutrition and
health
at this time we know that their excess
is affected by
income losses by mobility constraints
so it's both a matter of being able to
physically access food
economically excess food and that can
have
severe consequences for nutrition today
but also for growth and development
in the future we must protect the
vulnerable
now to safeguard the future of
generations
and of society and of course the
pandemic having huge
effects around the world but
particularly in low and middle income
countries they're really open and
vulnerable at the moment aren't they
they very much are they were already
very vulnerable
before this crisis hit and this crisis
really shows us uh where the weak points
uh
are and maybe i can just give an example
of
like a curfew for night transport
for any movement at night really
affecting transport of fresh foods to
markets for example which you can't
transport during the day when it's far
too hot
you have to transport it at night and a
curfew then prevents that from
from happening affecting hence the
availability of
good foods in markets and on top of all
this the
report also mentions food logistics
disruption
talking about it there forcing therefore
millions of people to try and look for
other ways to feed themselves but
they're turning to nutrient poor
alternatives yeah
so what they're actually trying to feed
themselves with is is doing them damage
yeah it's basically decreasing the
diversity of their diet so
then focusing on foods that are
non-perishable uh
which are of lower nutritional value
yeah
but how are you gonna you know
everyone's trying to deal with a
pandemic right now
everyone's kind of looking to their own
front door if you're liking countries
around
the world and you're really up against
it here trying to
convince various governments just to
give a a bigger global picture if you
like and be charitable
um you've got a huge job on your hands
here at the moment haven't you when as i
say everyone's looking to their own
front door
yeah this crisis is unprecedented it's
unprecedented for
families it's unprecedented for
countries it's unprecedented for
humanitarian actors
like ourselves we are really
looking at where the the critical points
are and trying to
mitigate and preempt situations as they
as they evolve if i can talk about our
food supply chains for example we really
want to make sure that
foods are fortified so we are adding
vitamins and minerals to rice
flour so one step then is to
ensure that the premix for doing so can
still reach
countries and can still reach the food
processors
another point is pre-positioning food
close to where it's
required um everything you've
highlighted in the
in this report the huge amount of money
that's going to cost as well 2.4 billion
dollars needed to protect them
children most in need is your voice
going to be heard is this report going
to make any difference end of the day
because of everything else that's going
on that's subsumed the world at the
moment coronavirus
yeah so that the report is accompanied
by a call to action from the
foreign heads of the the un agencies of
world health organization of unicef
of the food and agriculture organization
and of the world food programme
really to amplify the voice and to
set the priorities
and have that call for funding which
should come from
many different actors from donors but
also from governments themselves
through a prioritization of funds to
re-protect
nutrition and that protect the future of
generation finally even if this started
now even if you've got everything you
wished for
with everyone on board around the world
and the money you needed
how soon would it take to make a real
difference here you know is it going to
be years to try and tackle this or could
you make a
a big difference very quickly
differences can be can be made quickly
uh however we should also realize that
malnutrition and debt crisis in itself
uh did exist uh prior to covet and it's
now being amplified
um so we can mitigate the impact of uh
of kovit and
through that uh built back better for
better uh assistance well it's been a a
huge
eye-opener and it's been very well
received around the world what you're
trying to do there best of luck to you
all of us here sasuke to pay who's the
senior technical advisor for nutrition
at the united nations world food
programme
thanks for your time we'll let you get
on with your busy day then